hi there Steve here today I want to talk
about the importance of learning
languages slowly
maybe I'll speak more slowly and the
reason I thought of this is that you
know the last couple of days have been
working to build an area of Dec here in
front of my house where we used to have
a hot tub we yanked the hot tub and I'm
putting in sort of some decking you know
as well as sort of some paneling if you
want on the walls and as I do this I
keep on you know through a process of
trial and error how do I get the wall to
actually stand up and what length of
nails should I use or Rhett lengths of
screws and and creating little sections
of panel or at least decking that I
could put down as sections of three or
four pieces of wood so I can pull them
up and and I make a lot of mistakes so
there's a lot of doing it over again and
so some days it feels as if I've worked
you know five six hours on this thing
and I really haven't achieved very much
and then I thought about that and I
thought yeah but I actually enjoy doing
it I'm in the Sun I'm sawing or I'm
nailing or I'm looking at it and I'm
thinking of different ways I test about
different stains on the back of my
siding to see what I wanted to use and
some things were better than others and
and I enjoy it I enjoy doing it so even
though I'm not on any schedule I don't
work for a contractor I'm not being paid
by the hour I'm happy I'm happy doing it
and I thought you know my language
learning is a bit the same way so I'm
learning Arabic and I've exposed myself
to a little bit of Farsi and I at times
feel that that especially with Arabic
we're getting used to those two the
writing system reading it remains such a
chore because I'm not yet used to it and
so Sunday's I sort of think well I
should be moving along more quickly and
and then I thought to myself oh no
actually I enjoy it I enjoy the process
I enjoy being there with these Arabic
words
hearing them and stuff I enjoy listening
to it I enjoy what I'm already able to
do just as with a deck I enjoy what I
have already done although I haven't
moved along as quickly as I would like I
enjoy the fact that studying Arabic and
now a little bit of Farsi has you know
encouraged me to read up on the history
of Arab people and the history of
Persian and through that I discover
other things about ancient Greece and
Sparta and and discovered just the the
extent to which everything is
interconnected Persia Greece Arabs
Turkish world even Persia China I mean
all of our histories is connected and
you know my learning of or studying
Arabic and Persian the issue is not how
quickly can I get it done the issue is
that I'm enjoying doing it and therefore
I shouldn't put undue pressure and I
think people put pressure on themselves
I want to learn this in three months I
want to learn this in a short period of
time why haven't I made more progress if
we are enjoying the process if we are
putting in the time we are getting
better and maybe if we enjoy what we're
doing we don't want it to end we're in
no hurry
and maybe we shouldn't be in a hurry so
just a reflection is sort of based on my
experience in building my deck and
enjoying what I am doing although it
looks as if some days I haven't made any
significant progress and the same is
true of our language learning so enjoy
it
savor it learn slowly and learn in a way
that gives you a sense of fulfillment
that's kind of my thought for the day
bye for now
[Music]